welcome back to drew's news okay we want
to make a special shout out to the
incredible cardi b because she is
stepping up to support the families who
lost loved ones in the apartment
building fire in the bronx cardi is a
bronx girl herself and she is taking
care of all the funeral expenses for all
of the 17 victims families and it's such
a beautiful way to show support at such
a difficult time and our hearts go out
to all the families in the bronx and
thank you cardi again for being who you
are we salute you and we were so
inspired by the story that we had to
shout it out on our show thank you cardi
b hometown girl yeah amazing
um and now it is time for a pick from
drew's little yellow book and that's our
curation um that's very personal to me
we refresh it every single week on our
website and we pour over the details of
it and it's very meaningful so this week
i wanted to do something a little
different
i wanted to add this thing into the
little yellow book today because it
truly shifted my perspective
so this man recorded his girlfriend
every time he picked her up from work at
the end of the day
and the visual is just a complete
picture of joy
the thing that swept me up about it was
the way she walked out of work oh this
is her one bad day in it which actually
i think would be probably the majority
of how we walked out of work on an
average day
and i thought about the choices we make
and the body language we have and how it
is a bit of a choice that we could make
and i'm so inspired by this woman
that i too thought i should be putting a
skip in my step
and i was so inspired by her i wanted to
learn and i wish to talk to them and
they're here actually to say hi
oh we've got the couple behind the video
please welcome julius and julie hi guys
hello
julius what made you start recording in
the first place so initially
i
got in the routine of picking her up
from work and i noticed that she would
always
prance how to work to me
no matter no matter the situation most
times
and i was like you know what i should
start recording her every time and it
was planned to be just a birthday
surprise for her and um i posted it on
my tick tock so my followers could also
say
you know happy birthday to her on her
birthday it definitely took a
path that i never thought it was going
to take it's really affected people and
so i get to ask the source right now
hello julie i've been waiting to meet
you i'm so excited
i'm excited
what makes you do this and what can we
all learn from it
for me like i know that he's a light in
my life that i have so when i'm at work
and i'm in that mindset
once i get out of work it's that
anticipation that i've been feeling all
day to finally get to see him so like
when i walk through those doors i just
let my excitement you know
come out
release it
see him
because at the end of the day like he's
the person that i get to like unwind
with and fully be myself with and that's
just something that i look forward to
so it's so beautiful
i
i don't know what i walk look like
walking out of work and i'm a really
happy person you know
and i kind of want to start a movement
in honor of you guys
that's like a hashtag skip in your step
how can we
be like julie and show and feel and
exude our happiness and not hold it back
and lock it up inside of ourselves like
let's start this together
skipping your steps
[Applause]
in honor of julie and julius whether you
send it to julius's account or us at the
drewberrymore show
into our instagram our tic tac just
let's do this hashtag skipping your
stuff yeah honestly
bringing that joy into the physical
world and not shortchanging ourselves
thank you guys so much for coming on the
show and may i congratulate you i
understand you have a brand new baby
four months old
yes thank you so much
well congratulations thank you julie and
julia thanks guys
[Music]
you